oh garden the jewels dude your Gardens
jewels now everyone knows that I love
huge swords though our swords are huge
but they're still not quite big enough
let's see if Jerry can make a sword big
enough to impress me I fully grown duck
his name was Moliere you would never in
your life want to have a horse sized
duck unless you have a serious 50
caliber machine gun and could kill this
thing so you would take horses 100
horses a hundred horses
I would rather those are medium-sized
dogs makes me so happy cuz that's the
argument I've been making you don't want
to fight this duck and everyone else
hears like I could take the duck you
couldn't no you couldn't
I'm Tania I've had ducks I've owned
ducked and they can be mean mother and
this duck has begun its it has a little
pointy thing yeah it will hurt your ass
it will hurt you bad they do this and by
the way their beak is at crotch level so
yeah you're gardening the jewels dude
your Gardens jewels you get a full male
groan going for them
dude he's at that level and you see what
he can do to chicken bones he crushed it
looks like he's crushing him but what
he's probably doing is swallowing them
whole
I mean pork rinds ribs even chewed up
ribs you throw the rib on the gun
knowing how badass a duck can be when
it's it Honore or something like that a
hundred hundred hundred horses I mean
what the worst the horse could do is
take they bite you nicking mule kick you
right I'm still I can at least get to
higher ground the duck ducks can semi
fly yeah I had to put a top on my knight
and put a chicken wire top because this
dude was like I had a like a three foot
fence that I got at Home Depot that wire
fence and
sweat right over what he really wanted
given the difference of what I know the
duck I'm Moliere was a full sized male
grown duck and the only thing he the way
he died I was about 20 feet from him
when he died it was like dusk and a
giant opossum they can be big this one
was a big one and he was hungry and he
got in and got in a fight with Moliere
he he jumped up on its back and and bit
more years now and yeah hello don't go
for the doc welcome to round 2 I
swallowed a chip oh don't you hate when
the triangle goes down straight ah the
triangle almost past ah okay we're here
to talk about a new video dim souls
Clint spawns in through the grounds like
hi Nico because just like hey you have
to help me fight this boss also cool
sword by the way Nico has got a huge
sword but it cuts the clintons got even
bigger swords the Dark Souls huge weapon
let's see we're making what are we
making him we need to figure out how
Jarrett's going to make a giant prop I
think if you use really wide angle
lenses and use the sword we have you
could get the same effect super heavy
front of you dangerous will be careful
this sword that Sam's about to bring
over is that gonna work for the prop or
we're gonna have to build another way
I mean it's kind of huge now everyone
knows that I love huge swords though our
swords are huge but they're still not
quite big enough let's see if Jared can
make a sword big enough to impress me
how big it is yeah I mean it'll be funny
no green the words is it's not like
fighting a hundred duck-sized horses is
gonna be like an easy thing either cuz
horses when they bite they latch on they
don't let go they'll actually just mash
on stuff they just chew chew on
everything so I imagine like them biting
onto your calf and just like never
letting go oh oh no I've been bit by a
horse did I worked in a freaking horse
stable for a week I was done after that
he worked in I didn't know you worked in
a horse stable just one week I was a
horseman people rough man like I was
just like moving hey I was just picking
up hay and scoop and poop and like
moving stuff around you ever deal with
the horses yes dude see the horse and
then like like scoop out the poop and
the hay they would take the horse out to
scoop the poop and the hay out of their
place and like refill the water and like
whatever the heck and throw some carrots
in there all that good stuff I remember
one day I was just there for a week and
like the trainer was bringing the horse
back and as I just pet it yeah you can
they can smell your fear
and I was like oh god that was
terrifying and then like I go to like
touch things I was done dude I was out
no more stable I ain't moving hey for 20
bucks so did you quit yes I was on the
spot quit it was supposed to be two-week
thing I was like out after the week I
was like I'm done that was the last day
dude I was out in under 24 hours
seriously yeah it took him one hour
under 24 hours Jared felt this snores
Wow with the constraints he had I'm so
impressed of the result look at this
craftsmanship
I cannot believe he managed to get this
done Wow dangerous yes what is that it's
dangerous okay the problem is that you
said we needed a sword that was like 15
feet long but we failed to like go into
more detail did you know that it's
supposed to be like a big sword and this
is pretty big sorry let me rephrase that
did you know that it's supposed to be a
greater scale on sword as it like this
is a normal sword you know and the sword
that we were intending to build it was
supposed to be built at a ratio of like
400% oh well I mean scales overrated
this is this is still big Sam are you
okay with this dude this whole studio
used to be full of square spaces and
they're all mysteriously gone I have no
idea what happened they should be here
because Squarespace is the most
beautiful way to present your ideas
online yeah they have beautiful designer
templates don't have any Squarespace is
here
no this
dude see they're gone there's no square
space in here the rectangle dude no dude
no that's not my point dude there was a
bunch of them in here they they have an
all-in-one platform so there's nothing
to install patcher upgrade ever and they
were all in here something's definitely
up there just mysteriously gone nothing
in here this is super weird dude this
was just there the square space that was
just there I just walked by it I don't
think you understand me they have 24/7
award-winning customer service and
it was just right here Squarespace has a
unique domain experience that's fully
transparent and easy to set up and it's
flexible for any kind of website so
whether you're a musician an
entrepreneur or an online store it's
flexible for you what's going on here
man you just had to keep asking
questions didn't you look I just was
trying to get the truth I don't I didn't
know what happened man that's what Peter
said that's what Peter to said you just
had to keep digging where you weren't
supposed to dig huh don't do anything
stupid why don't you just do yourself a
favor and walk away go to
squarespace.com slash corridor crew and
you'll get 10% off your first purchase
and we don't got to worry about none of
this it's much bigger than me Jake
[Music]
the links into the description of the
video you didn't see any of this named
uncle leaders we're filming our Dark
Souls video I just woke up my passion
airs like this because I didn't shave
for a month and a half straight until
you're like hey guys let's shave our
facial hair in two ridiculous styles
that we've never done before
and it lined up perfectly with this
video it's perfect it's fantastic I
can't even see dude I don't know what to
say I'm like dude I woke up like 45
minutes ago man cuz then you could have
it up no such thing is a non J key
battle helmet even under brand new
that's still falling apart this isn't
last minute this is like all right on
schedule
you could be all dark and cool-looking
so the most important thing to protect
is your crotch you don't want to get
these guys chopped off so and you know I
got you know just the leather the cheap
leather my uggs to keep me warm and cozy
we got inverse go to you see this if you
put them together they'll make a hole go
team
and
perfect I think that's around yay